[Music]
hello everyone
uh thanks for having me today it's a
real honor to be able to speak to you
all
um my name is john bernock i'm going to
be talking for the next 40 minutes or so
about
the lessons that i've learned from
visualizing the kovid 19 pandemic
over well i guess it's now about 12
months
um so to set the scene what i want to do
is
start off by talking about the
perspective i'm coming from
in this talk so data visualization is
obviously
an enormously broad church
there's all sorts of different uses for
database in different settings
but what i'm talking about today
specifically is data visualization from
a mass audience now as a visual
journalist
i'm always dealing with a large audience
to some extent
and the financial times is behind a
paywall so it's perhaps not
the largest audience of all um but
what's really
changed dramatically over the last year
working on the pandemic is that that
audience has become
enormous it's become truly global and it
was quite obvious from as early as
the the sort of first couple of weeks of
march
2020 that i was suddenly
my charts were suddenly being seen by an
audience of millions across the world
instead of just the
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands who would typically see them
on the financial times website so the
principles i'm going to be talking about
today
and the best practices are all geared
towards
communicating to a hugely diverse
audience of people in terms of their
familiarity with charts
i'm not saying that what i recommend
today is going to be the case if you're
producing a visual installation for an
art gallery or a sort of coffee table
style
piece of work but really just thinking
about data visualization fundamentally
is an
act of communication and particularly of
mass
communication so to start with something
that
i suspect reads is incredibly obvious
but i think is actually
relatively little discussed in the date
of this world
i'm going to talk about the fact that to
create really effective really powerful
charts
you really need to understand how people
consume charts
now to sort of talk a little bit about
why that's not as obvious as it might
think
um if you look online at the numbers of
tutorials there are
for making graphics making data bits
whether it's in r
python d3 you name it generally they're
focused on the technical
element of constructing a chart what
chart type to choose
how to get your geometries your shape
space and color exactly right
how to do things more efficiently
optimizing interactivity that kind of
thing
there's relatively little on thinking
about
what more qualitative elements
you can optimize to ensure that people
understand enjoy and remember your
chance
and you know this is where i i perhaps
get almost a bit too sort of
corporate or business focused in my view
of this but
when you're making charts for a mass
audience it it serves you well i think
to think about them almost as if you're
creating
an advert like there is decades of
research from people who
create billboard ads for example on
what you should do in terms of messaging
in terms of
how you use text in terms of how you use
color and all of that
to elicit a specific response in your
audience
and i think it's that communications way
of thinking
that is relatively underrepresented at
the moment in best practice guidelines
for charts
so as i say when i've been creating
charts that i'm
hoping and laterally expecting going to
be seen by an audience of millions
i've really had to focus on first of all
how do i ensure they're clear enough
to reach and be easily understood by
millions of people
and and then how do i make sure that
they stick in their memory and they're
not just
you know post 79 out of 100 that
ping on their twitter feed every day
so without any further ado and i think
quite fittingly given that i'm talking
about lessons
about from the pandemic it's time to
look at the science
so i'm going to show you here some work
that is not my own work
but it's probably the single most
influential
database research paper that i've ever
come across and it's one that
i and why the team at the ft use very
frequently and constantly have in our
mind when we're thinking about
how to optimize our work for
understanding biomass audience
and that is this paper from a team led
by michel borkin in the us
on what it is what are the
characteristics of visualizations that
lead people to
recognize the story of that graphic and
then to recall it later on
so the slide i'm going to show you in a
second is
looking at an eye tracking experiment
from this paper
and i'm going to show you a gif so it's
going to loop if you don't see it first
time that's fine it'll come again
but what it is is it's showing where
people's eyes actually focus when
they're given a chart
for a relatively short period of time 10
seconds 30 seconds or so
and asked what do you see here what can
you make out what's the main takeaway
and so what you're going to see is a
sort of simple
illustration of a chart and then a blue
dot on that chart showing where people
look
when they're presented with that chart
and what you see is that blue dot moves
straight up to the title of the chart
has a little explorer of the title then
comes down and reads off the axis label
to see
what units the chart is showing and then
reads across the chart content itself
i'll just let that play again so the
eyes go to the title
they then come down to see the vertical
axis and then they read across
the contents of the chart the key point
here
is that that initial focus goes straight
to the title
and the researchers did additional
follow-up analysis of the same
group of participants and found that
when people later on were asked to
remember
any any information about a chart and
just write a sort of freeform
description of what they'd seen
words featured very prominently the
title any
annotations labeling were all mentioned
far more often
when people remember the chart than the
actual visual content of the plot
itself and that is something we
really sort of center on in our work at
the ft our view
is very much that you know you can make
a
a stunning chart you can have all your
geometry right it can be technically
executed perfectly
but if the messaging if the text is
absent
in the worst case scenario or too
sterile too dry
you're going to lose a hell of a lot of
people and the way
i like to think about that is that your
text can help your chart
be understandable enjoyable and
memorable for someone who is quote
unquote not a chart person
those of us on uh those of us watching
or participating in the conference today
i'm sure consider ourselves chart people
or data people to a greater or lesser
extent and that means
when we see a chart it's already a thing
that we're familiar with
that we like and that we have a sort of
way of understanding
whereas there are millions and millions
of millions of people out there
a lot more non-child people than child
people as it were
who need that helping hand so
to give you an example from the pandemic
of this sort of way of thinking in
action i'm going to talk through the
origin story as it were of our
coronavirus trajectory
tracker so probably the most high
profile chart that we've
put out over the last 12 months and i'm
going to start by showing
how this was sparked how this came about
by showing you an email i got from one
of my colleagues
on i think this was march the 10th or
11th
and so she's one of our general news
reporters who was covering this sort of
nascent
um pandemic back then or certainly the
nation epidemic as far as the uk and
europe was concerned
um and she just asked me she's wondering
if i had any data on
daily cases in italy which of course at
the time was sort of the
the focus of all the world's attention
there were grim pictures coming out of
there in the news reports of
bodies in morgues and that kind of thing
um
and she's asking me okay do we have any
data on daily cases for italy and can we
compare that to the uk perhaps other
countries as well
so you haven't managed to find that data
anywhere else and so i
rustled up that same afternoon or
evening or whatever it was
a quick version sort of version version
0.0
um as it were of what became our
high-profile trajectory trackers
so you can see for those of you who
remember the
final version of this chart i have
encountered the vital version of this
chart
the geometry what what is shown what is
plotted here
is essentially unchanged from the final
version we've got the number of days
since the country first reached its
100th confirmed case
going horizontally and then you've got a
log
scale a logarithmic y-axis of the total
number
cumulative number of confirmed cases up
to that point
and a set of countries shown on there
colored by
things like their global region or other
aspects that i'll come up to in a minute
but obviously you know if i published
that i doubt it would have cut through
um to a huge audience the way it
ultimately did there's nothing here
really telling you what's going on
there's a lot of assumed knowledge
obviously i sent that to my colleague in
the context of this email chain we both
knew what we were talking about looking
at
but if i just put this if we publish
this on the ft on social
media you know a few people again chart
people or
covey data people would have thought ah
right interesting
but it wouldn't have had any sort of
mass resonance
so here's the next version of this
when it's been styled as um as we style
all our charts on the financial times so
we've got that
trademark sort of salmon pink background
i'm now using the colors from our main
color palette again doing some sort of
semantic use of color there so i'm
highlighting
some asian countries in this sort of
light blue i've got south korea in a
different blue because it wasn't clear
what trajectory was on by that point
and a few other colors dotted around
there's a bit more text on the chart now
and we've got both axes labeled
i've got that source and footnote at the
bottom as well but again
sure this in terms of aesthetics in
terms of design this is now
neater this is a better fit for what we
would publish on the ft
but it's still missing those crucial
ingredients so here's the final version
that was published i think this was
on march the 12th so still about two
weeks before the uk
for example actually went into down and
now we've got all of that additional
labeling added again going back to that
research these are the key
bits of information that are going to be
the first thing that someone
encountering this chart
focuses on and they're going to set the
scene for everything else that they take
away from it
so we've got a title a very active title
descriptive narrative title that most
western countries were on the same
coronavirus trajectories
hong kong and singapore by contrast and
managed to slow this bread
so straight away you've got a message
which grabs you which brings you in and
which tells you something that is
happening in the world
the fact that there's a chart here as
well is almost incidental i mean maybe
maybe i'm exaggerating there but the
point is whether or not you are
someone who builds and works with
database multiple times a day
or someone who last really spent any
time with charts when you're age
16 and doing some compulsory maths or
science education
whichever of those groups you fall into
the words here tell you what's going on
and so if you are someone who doesn't
consider themselves a chart person
you've got your entry point you can now
understand the geometry of the chart you
can
work out what's going on with the lines
with the shape with the space with the
color
because you know what message it's
trying to tell
if the chart simply said cumulative
number of cases by number of dates in
100 case as the title
that's a hell of a lot more technical
there's a lot more jargon and it's going
to be much less accessible
to people who are not familiar with
charts the other thing we've obviously
got here
is these annotations towards the right
hand side actually explaining some of
the stuff you can see on the chart
so this is more geared towards someone
who is not
has not been following the pandemic and
code
data in a huge amount of detail they
immediately have
the queries that they would have had of
this chart answered
so they can see oh right so japan its
line is further down
um the virus is spreading less fast
there and less widely
but we can see that it's not quite clear
yet whether the spread has actually
slowed in japan or they're not doing
enough testing
korea we can see which was of course the
big focus here is as we were looking for
how countries could get off that steep
curve and flatten
we've got an explanation there about how
it has slowed its spread from the
initial pace
and you can also look at singapore and
hong kong and see what they have done
right
so that text when we looked at what
people were talking about
around the context of this graphic on
social media and on the financial times
website
that text was the key part that really
seemed to cut through and cause people
to keep coming back to this chart
and indeed to share this chart with
other people so the first
lesson um of the pandemic for me i think
was that
using text another annotation is really
critical
for making sure a chart goes from being
a chart for date of his people shall we
say
to a chart that is truly accessible um
to a really mass audience of people who
haven't been that they're not involved
in charts and data
every day and suddenly but suddenly this
is the sort of democratization of charts
by using text to make them more
accessible
the next lesson and this is for me one
of the most fundamental lessons anyone
can learn
in the process of building database is
that there's a big difference between
making the
the smartest version of a chart you
possibly can and the clearest version
of a shot you possibly can as with
everything there are obviously
exceptions where you can do both of
these things
but during the pandemic i think they've
been several examples of how these
really
do these really are in tension with one
another a lot of the time
so sometimes and this was more the case
i think in the earlier part of my career
um but it's still it's still a recurring
theme and i think this is something that
a lot of people
here today will recognize as well
sometimes we can get into the habit of
thinking that
effective data visualization is about
optimizing for
precision and objectivity there's a sort
of
list of technical um tasks
and if you nail every one of them you'll
make the perfect chart
you're using maths and geometry to
arrive at the best solution it's a very
sort of
technical um structured process
but then i actually publish a chart and
it suddenly becomes
very clear that that is simply not the
case that is a
convenient but very rarely true
description of what we should be
aiming for when we make a data
visualization
so i'm going to come back to this same
chart and talk through
all of the clever technical things that
i thought i was doing with this chart
when i made it
and then how the chart then when the
chart encountered reality shall we say
a lot of my assumptions were turned um
on their head
so the first difference and i'm just
gonna flick back between
these two charts this is the one that
i've shown you already this was the
data plotted on a logarithmic y-axis the
point of this
was to say well we know that the
pandemic especially in the early stage
spreads exponentially so
the shape of the curves on this chart
if we plotted it on a linear axis on a
linear scale they would all be arcing
upwards from gentle slopes to steep
slopes
and to me you're using a lot of visual
bandwidth there just to show something
that we assume
is the default that all of these curves
are going to be getting steeper and
steeper in these early weeks
so by going for a log scale you sort of
free up more bandwidth as it were in the
reader's head
and you allow them to focus on what
matters which is you can now do
the key thing that readers at this stage
wanted to do which is compare the
trajectories of different countries
on a straight line you can look at this
and say okay
the virus seems to be spreading more
quickly in spain than in france
and france in turn more quickly than the
uk
you can also because it's a straight
line you can forecast out ahead and work
out
where the rate of cases in your country
is going to be
a few days or a week further down the
line you can answer that critical
question that we set out to answer here
if we refer back to my colleague's email
which is how our country's doing
compared to italy
you can answer that much more easily
with these straight lines that are easy
to extrapolate
than with the curves where it's harder
to work out exactly where a line will be
at a certain point in time
so my thinking here was all framed
around this idea that when someone's
looking at this chart
there's a whole sort of framework
they're operating in that that
determines what their takeaway message
is
is about are these two countries or
three countries on the same course
or how many days until the country i'm
interested in
is at a certain level of cases that i
know sort of
means something and therefore that
they're not thinking
well how many pixels represent 100 cases
they're not worried about
what's going on on the y-axis they're
looking for more of a sort of
overarching message
however let's have a look at some of the
feedback that started pouring into that
and i'll say just as a quick aside here
um for anyone who isn't in the habit of
publishing their work on social media
now i know it's not for everyone and
there are certainly some somewhat
sub-optimal features of twitter shall we
say but it's an incredible way
to work out what does and doesn't work
in a chart
and to gauge the sort of reaction again
of
both chart people and non-chart people
very quickly
um so i was inundated with messages
around responding to these charts for
week after week after week and
continue to be this year but this was a
snapshot of some of the initial feedback
to that chart now obviously
loads of people understood the log x log
x is fine
but you know any critical feedback is
always worth paying attention to
and the fact that the majority of people
got it doesn't negate the fact that
plenty of people didn't
so lots of people here very confused by
what's going on in the y-axis some of
them
perhaps know what a log scale is but
just thought it wasn't clearly explained
others clearly are just baffled
and that's not reaction you want with
your chart however
my response to that was not just not to
just think oh right
okay like back to the drawing board
start again um
it's got to be linear people aren't
getting this my response was to think
okay i've got a i'm in i'm in an
advantageous position here that
i'm on twitter where i'm presenting
these charts
and this is a space where i can continue
these conversations
so what i did was i immediately posted a
long
explanation well not too long but a
relatively thorough explanation of
exactly why
logarithmic y axes were well suited to
visualizing data that grows
exponentially that got a very good
response
and we followed up on that at the ft by
actually making a whole video explainer
which talked about all of the decisions
we were making when we made these charts
and how to understand them
and this seemed to work really really
well in terms of
softening some of that initial um
confusion that some people had to the
chart and my favorite thing about this
is that
what you get when you do this kind of
work what you'll see when you
explain things clearly um and have them
in the public domain
whether it's twitter facebook whatever
is
your like the other your audience will
start
helping you explain this stuff to other
people so what we started to see quite
soon was
these are other people jumping into the
replies to me
explaining to the people who've been
confused look this is a log scale this
is what they do
don't worry about it um i'm actually
pointing
people to the video where i'd explain
this so by
instead of thinking um well you know
i've just
published the chart i'm done i'm going
to walk away by sort of staying
in that conversation around the chart i
was able to
ensure that as few people as possible
actually remained confused
and to really try and improve
understanding of log scales full stop
and just as a quick aside um something i
find quite amusing when i look back at
these messages is that you'll see on the
left hand side there
two of the people who'd been confused by
the log scale
well one of them their account is now
suspended and the other one their
account no longer exists so i like to
think of that as being a little
example that people who don't understand
log scales
um have other failings in live show we
say that
we've been to be kicked off twitter
anyway back to the important stuff
um all of this about log scales and
people
perhaps initially not understanding them
but gradually getting their heads around
and brings me on to what
in a in a huge sea of contenders is
actually my favorite chart of the
pandemic
and that is this and what you're looking
at here is
data from google trends who which for
the unfamiliar is
measuring how much search interest on
google there is for topics over time
and what we see here is this is the
numbers of people worldwide
searching for log scale on google
and i've got that going back for the
last five years or so
so from late 2015 through to um
early well the start of sorry through to
so from late 2015 through to mid 2020
and what you see there is a big spike
searches for log scale in that five-year
period
reached their peak on around the 22nd of
march 2020
and coincidentally that was about a week
after we started
publishing these log scale charts on the
ft
and the the interest the numbers of
people looking at those charts have
really wrapped up over that week
so i don't think it's unreasonable
for me and for us at the ft to think
that the proliferation
of log-scale charts and our use of
explainers around them
really did help actually educate a hell
of a lot of people on what love scales
are
and i know that from other anecdotal
evidence as well i had to of
school friends who i've not spoken to
for 15 years getting in touch saying
they were
explaining my chance to their mom and
that kind of thing so it was a real
demonstration that
by sticking around and actually
explaining what your chart is showing to
people
you can really help people become more
visually literate so the lesson there
yeah is that
if there is confusion around a chart
that you've made
that's on you like it's no good just
saying oh how do these people not
understand log scales
you've got to do the work to make sure
that the people
you've got to do the work to make sure
that your audience is not left confused
and the key point here for me as well is
doing this additional
explanation in situ doing this
explanation where the chart appeared
it's not much use publishing a chart
over here and then
a few days later explaining how it was
meant to work over here
you've got to try and do that where your
audience is
so that they are not going to get lost
along the way and walk away
scratching their head but there's more
um the reactions these log scales were
not
purely about the log scales or about the
geometry about the space about the
numbers
when you look at some of these other
responses a lot of them were much more
qualitative or they were quite personal
in some cases they were even political
so i'm sure i don't need to explain to
everyone that
the pandemic covid has all become quite
politicized
quite um partisan over the last year
you know there are camps of pro
massacres and anti-massacres
pro-lockdown anti-lockdown all of this
stuff and
it turns out that the use of log scales
in charts is actually
another example of this so we had some
people saying that
they felt like the use of a log scale
was
sort of uh dampening the impact of
increased
of increased numbers of cases so a line
went up and up and up it then started to
gradually flatten
as the rate of increase slowed even if
the numbers were still going up
so people felt like um we were
diminishing
we were we were downplaying the impact
of increased spread as time went on
because those lines were
were becoming flatter whereas if they
were linear they'd been going straight
upwards
um and yeah people really felt that we
were perhaps trying to make some kind of
political point here
and trying to suggest that in the uk for
example things weren't as bad as they
were
so the clear takeaway from that seems to
be that
quite apart from people reacting to the
actual data and geometry in your charts
they're going to come in with all sorts
of baggage as it were in terms of
their understandings and feelings about
the subject matter
and there may be decisions that you made
in the construction of your charts that
you felt were purely
technical purely to do with database
but people are actually going to read
into that a lot more than what you
intended
so generally there seemed to be two caps
of people roughly who would look at
these charts there are people who
like us on on this in this session today
who would just look at these numbers and
think
all right okay what's going on there
very a very sort of analytical way of
um analyzing the chart but there was a
huge number of others
who and i think this goes back to my
first point really as well about the use
of text and how people understand charts
they would just take away a single
overarching message from these charts
and so they would look at something
where the lines were sort of becoming a
bit more gentle
and they would think oh this this chart
is trying to say things aren't actually
that bad at all
and so it's just a really interesting
demonstration of how you kind of need to
cater to those needs you don't want
someone
to have a negative reaction to your
chart based on
some design choice that you made even if
you haven't realized what impact it was
going to have
um so yeah this this can lead people to
completely sort of
throw out the baby with the bath water
they'll come they'll decide that this
chart is
wrong you know it's worthless it's junk
because
it has this it jars with their
understanding of the subject matter
so this is the next lesson for us which
was that
information visualization database is
much
is about much more than just pixels on a
page in geometry
um and shape and space and color it's
about the whole feeling that something
creates and
and whether that meshes with or jars
with someone's
perceptions of the topic at hand so
we need to think about that when we're
producing a chart especially on a
divisive or sort of
sensitive topic like this and minimize
the risk that someone's going to react
badly
because of some choices that we've
consciously made in the geometry
if someone's objecting to the data
itself that's their problem you know
someone was looking at this chart and
saying
um oh why are you showing
covered cases going up when the pandemic
is over well that would be
flat out wrong because copy cases were
going up but if someone's objecting to
the use of a different scale for example
and the the tone the feel that that
gives to your chart
i think that's that's not unreasonable
their feelings are what their feelings
are
and it's important for us to consider
that when we're um designing our charts
so what we did in the end of the ft was
we turned
these static graphics that we've been
producing every day
with a log scale into an interactive
piece where you can choose between log
or linear so anyone then complaining
about not understanding
or being mislead by the use of the log
scale for example
could then flip between the two toggled
between the two on our page here and
that's what
many many many people have done over the
course of the last year
the next point and this comes back to
what i was saying earlier about the
value of something like social media or
whatever platform you're publishing your
charts on
um and i want to talk about how you can
gain an enormous amount
from thinking about database again as a
fundamental act of communication as a
dialogue so instead of just throwing
your chart out there and walking away
explosions in the background as it were
and stick around
get into the conversation and see what
you can learn and what you can gain
from those conversations about the work
that you've done
and i just i think it's i feel so
fortunate as it were
to have had the number of interactions
i've had with people
all over the world from all walks of
life all levels of data and visual
literacy
about the charts that i've built because
i have
now an enormous an enormous amount of
information on what people have liked
what people haven't liked what people
have struggled with what people have
been
challenged by but risen to what people
have just sort of thrown their hands up
and not liked at all and so getting into
those conversations i think it's
absolutely critical whether you're
publishing this as a journalist to a
mass audience
whether it's to colleagues at your
workplace um
wherever it is so to do that
one thing we did very explicitly from
quite early on in our
sort of visual coverage of the pandemic
was we explicitly solicited this kind of
feedback
because sure as i've shown you with some
of those responses to the log scales
the nature of twitter is that you will
get feedback whether you're asked for it
or not
but i think as anyone who's thought
about this for any amount of time knows
the quality of feedback you'll get goes
up through the roof
or exponentially one might say when you
actually ask for that
because first of all there are a hell of
a lot of people
the majority of people um in fact
aren't just going to randomly
hit a stranger with a load of thoughts
on the work that they've just done
a lot of people are polite or they're
shy or you know this isn't just this is
just not how they work online
whereas when you actively go out there
and say let us know what you think about
this
the stuff that we've been doing here
what do you think of these charts do
they work did they not
any other thoughts you have first of all
you're opening the door you're
telling these people who are maybe more
um introverted or
just don't see it as their place to
comment you're telling them that yeah we
want to hear your thoughts
um but you're also you're also
i think making that any criticism you
receive
much more likely to be constructed
because people now know that their
criticism is going to be acted upon
and they're not just sort of shouting
into the screen
so we would explicitly ask for feedback
over email
over twitter direct messages in the
replies we actually ended up setting up
a completely separate inbox
just for people to talk to us about
these charts
and this is just a snapshot from one day
in april and i've
this was a full screen of um gmail but
this one day's message is spammed more
than one full screen
so we've i think this was we had about
100 messages in one day
about this chart and i don't think
people will be able to read the text
there but if i just talk through the
range of stuff we were getting here
we've got people pointing us to data
sources that we didn't know about before
for countries in the world that we
didn't previously include in our charts
we've got people um pointing out things
that they struggle with and would like
us to change in our charts
we've got people just thanking us for
doing these charts we've got
people who may be a bit less politely
just saying i didn't like this
we've got people asking us to include
different charts we've got people coming
to us with story ideas
an enormous range of information that
both as
both in terms of how we um iterate on
this database
and how we just cover the pandemic more
broadly were incredibly
incredibly valuable and none of this
information would have come to us
if we hadn't set up this inbox if we
hadn't asked people to send this to us
so the lesson there i think is very
clear which is that
we if we want to you know do our do the
best that we can do
as data visualization practitioners both
in terms of
improving the work that we do through
feedback
and in terms of just reaching
effectively reaching as many people as
possible and making them feel like
charts and data visas are for them and
not just for
data nerds continued communication is
absolutely critical
so i might suggest for example that you
might want to put
a contact email or twitter handle or
whatever
works best for you on your charts
sometimes so that
wherever someone encounters this piece
of work in the wild
they'll know they can come to you and
they can give you thoughts i just feel
like it's so invaluable and you will
learn
so much about what does and doesn't work
and the shades of gray in between
by doing this whereas i think there's
often a tendency for us in database
to see our job as just making a thing
and then we put the thing out there and
we forget about it
but really really if there's one thing i
can get to you
from today is don't do that stick around
enjoy the chat
the next point um big big learning curve
for me
and again that audience feedback was
absolutely critical to this was
the risk of trying to be too clever
trying to be too technical with
solutions to
database problems and essentially losing
people along the way and losing trust
along the way so the term blinding with
science i'm sure most of you familiar
with but for those who aren't it's the
idea that you
you're telling someone about something
in an overly complex or technical way
so that regardless of the the result of
what you've done
they end up going away scratching their
head they're not quite sure
because of the terminology because of
the methodology they're not quite sure
what you've done
and i think there's often a risk with
that in database so
the question that we had um this was
still back in the spring
was could we improve the way we drew the
lines on our charts
so that instead of using a simple seven
day rolling average as we had been doing
we got slightly smoother lines but we
also got lines where the final data
point on the chart was a
more faithful reflection of the final
data point in real life
because of course the problem when
you're doing a seven day average whether
you
align that seven day average to the
right to the middle to the left
is it's never going to be a especially
close representation of the last
data point you have because it's being
influenced by the other six
and so the issue we were having is the
numbers
in our headlines in our news stories at
the ft would always be referring to that
last data point the thing that has just
happened
but our charts were referring to the
seven day average which was
while cases were going up always lower
than that and so we would have this
tension where
the numbers on our charts didn't quite
reflect the numbers we used
so what we decided to do was look at
whether we could optimize the way we
actually draw the lines on the chart so
that they're still smooth
as you get with an average but they also
actually
more faithfully reflect the very latest
data point you have
so for those of you who have only ever
seen seven day average charts of covert
data
this is what the underlying data
actually looks like it's incredibly
noisy you get these
huge peaks and troughs um new daily
cases will
drop to zero and then shoot up to a
thousand the next day because
the there are the way that this data is
actually collected and reported
leads to enormous um differences
in the numbers you get from day to day
there's weekly cyclicality there's all
sorts of stuff going on
so we definitely didn't want the data to
look like this now
of course the last point of each line
here would reflect reality would reflect
the last data point we had
but it's far too noisy we can publish
that so here's the rolling average
method we have been using
much clearer much smoother you can see
exactly what's going on you get
clear trends over time you can see here
for example that italy had
reached its peak and started coming back
down but
the last data point on each of these
lines didn't necessarily match up with
the last data point that had been
recorded
so what we considered was a smoothing
spline
so it keeps that smoothness of the lines
it's still relatively easy to discern
what's going on in one country
and compare it to another but the last
data point is now
because of how the splines are
calculated much closer to the last data
point that have been recorded
and you can see that in this next chart
so we actually measured
how close to the final
reported data point was the last data
point of each line
when we use this method on the left hand
side you've got a simple rolling average
on the right hand side you've got the
spline
and you can see that the data points are
much closer to the real reported value
on the right
so we decided let's switch over to the
spline
and we did again a long explainer
of why we've done this um setting out
that need to
to better represent the most recent data
while keeping smoothness
big explanation out in the public for
anyone to see
and i then again following my own advice
ask people what do they think
and here's the kind of responses we got
and what you'll notice is there were
sort of two
quite clearly different camps here on
the left
top left we've got a couple of people
saying spline's much better i
yeah i'm very devoted to spoiling myself
for example
and the thing i should point out
immediately about that is that
these two people peter and mike and i
don't know if any either of them are
actually
um watching along today are both um
data scientists to some degree so you
know i think anyone who's heard of
splines was
very i felt very positive about that as
an idea
um but then we get some different
feedback in the upper right we've got
someone saying the rolling average is
much easier for the average person to
understand
and in the lower left we've got someone
with a data science background but still
saying that the rolling average
probably makes more sense and then in
the lower left is we actually have one
of the epidemiologists in the uk
working on the development of the
vaccines
talking about how this is for the
general public
these the audience for this work is a
mass audience it's a very
an audience with very mixed visual and
data literacy and it's much easier for
people to get
their head around a seven day average
than a spline
so different people different with
different um personal contexts
had very different views on this so
the takeaway that we had again from this
was that you have to prioritize the ease
of understanding you may have come up
with an incredibly
technical nifty solution that on the
basis of any sort of quantitative
tests works better but if that is going
to confuse people along the way
that is a problem and again for me the
fundamental goal of my data
visualizations is communication with a
mass audience
and i would rather have clear
communication
and as many people as possible
understanding
remembering and wanting to share these
charts than to have something which is
five percent more uh correct
shall we say but that loses a lot of
people along the way
the final lesson that we've learned just
in the last couple of weeks i think in
our
work on the pandemic has been the
importance
and just the way that you can use
animation
to tell a story much much more
effectively than telling that same story
in a static
chart and so i've done
i've done a couple of bits of animation
over the last couple of years which have
been especially effective
and i think the lesson i've really
learned from this is that it's
the the sense of tension and of
anticipation that you can build up
when you do animation well um
can produce a much much stronger
response from people a much stronger
reaction
than doing exactly the same chart as a
static chart so i'm going to show you
two examples of that and there are
examples that some of you may have seen
in recent days which are where i wanted
to make the point
that covid really is considerably worse
for example
than a bad flu so here's the first chart
and what we're looking at here this
again this is a gif it's an animation
it's going to loop so if you miss it the
first time we'll see it the second time
we're looking at the weekly rate of
people admitted into icu so intensive
care units
in england with flu in a typical winter
over the last few years and then
contrasting that with what we've seen
this year for covid
and you'll see quite clearly that fluid
missions in the past were
even when we thought they were high so
even when we had what at the time were
seen as record bad
flu winters those figures were much
much lower than what we've seen over the
last month or two
in england with covid so this was really
attempt to
put to bed this myth this idea that oh
kovid's just
you know it just flew rebranded it's a
new version of what we've seen before
and show that this really is a
completely different beast
now some people would come back to this
and say well you know we're just testing
a lot more for kobe this year
so that's why we see the numbers we see
much higher numbers than we usually
would with flu
but again i had another animated
response to that which is to show the
total numbers of people in icu
in intensive care in london london uk
for any reason and compare that again
from winter to winter
so in a typical year even during a bad
flu season
the numbers of people in intensive care
in london never go above about 750
so again this is whether they're in
there for flu whether they're in there
for a heart attack for a stroke any any
of that but the numbers
of people in there for all causes never
really go above about 750 and are
typically around 700
whereas this year they've gone up above
1200 and in fact in recent days have
gone closer to 1400
so almost double the number of people in
intensive care in london this year than
a usual year
and unless there's been a sudden surge
in the numbers of people
falling down multiple flights of stairs
we can point to the one thing that is
different about this year which is coded
but the point is for a what i consider
to be a really important
topic here which is correcting
relatively widely held myths
that what we were seeing this winter was
nothing out of the ordinary and
therefore
we don't need to be in lockdown we don't
need any restrictions because this is
just like any other winter
you gain an enormous amount by producing
this as an animation
it's it's a much more engaging piece of
work
and this graphic on twitter alone has
now been seen
by more than 10 million people which is
far more people have seen this graphic
than any other chart that we produce at
the ft
all year on social media and that i
think
and in fact it's not just what i think a
lot of the responses on social media
have explicitly
pointed to this the use of animation was
enormously
was pivotal to that in terms of how it
grabs attention more than a static chart
in terms of how it builds suspense and
in terms of how you get that shock that
surprise factor at the end when you
compare the two
so the key point there being where it
where it's suitable
animation is an incredibly powerful
technique to use to convey a message now
i think it should be used sparingly if
you suddenly make everything animated
it becomes it's like the the old days of
90s internet where you've got pop-ups
everywhere um
everything's too noisy it's hard to
actually get across your key point and
everything gets drowned out
but using animation sparingly i think is
an incredibly powerful technique
so all of that is to say that the last
12 months i think have been
an incredible crash course for me and
for our team at the ft
in terms of really getting to the
fundamentals of how people do
read charts and therefore what we should
be thinking about when we make charts
what we should be focusing on
prioritizing
and coming into this year i think
my assumption and a lot of people here
i'm sure the assumption would have been
that
people read charts a bit like this they
get out their protractor their set
square their ruler
and their their compass and they it's
all about precision and
people are really focusing on individual
pixels and
and where different elements are in your
plot when they're trying to take away
their message they're
they're almost trying to pass the data
set back out of your chart and so
you as the practitioner should really be
focusing on the most high fidelity
most clear encoding of that data as
possible
um but the reality i think is actually a
bit more like this
it's a bit more like people going to a
movie theater and sitting back and
watching
they are coming to a chart to
see something to see some kind of story
to see
to get a message to to take away
something that is playing out in front
of them
you know in some cases literally with
the animation but in other cases it's
the line chart
but it's a line chart where they're not
focusing on
you know tiny differences between data
points on the chart they're focusing on
what is this top line message in the
title what's the takeaway here
and what are the other sort of sweeping
trends that this chart is conveying
they're not poring over it trying to
extract the values from every pixel on
the page
so to summarize the key lessons i think
i've learned here and i
i think these are lessons that i'm going
to be using for the rest of my my career
um first of all text is critical i know
we're all in the
database industry we make charts but if
we don't get the text right
none of the rest really matters people
will be lost they'll be confused
it will all be a disaster the second
point we have to take responsibility
if someone is confused about our chart
that's our fault and the best thing we
can do to combat that is to include
explanations um in situ
around where that chart appears to make
sure that there's as little risk as
possible confusion
on a similar note we need to be
considering
what are people's beliefs feelings
emotions sentiments around this subject
matter and how could they color their
reaction to this chart
how can we design this chart in as
neutral a way as possible in that sense
so that at least if anyone does have any
issues with their chart it's because
they don't like the data
it's not because they feel put off
or hurt somehow by the way we've
actually conveyed the information
the next step and i think again one of
the most important don't just publish
and vanish
stick around get involved in the
conversation you will learn so much
about how people are understanding your
chart that you can
incorporate into the next one you make
and
make sure that your chart above all else
is easy to understand
it doesn't matter if you can fine tune
it to make it
two three four percent more um
more faithful to the data it doesn't
even matter i think as much as
it doesn't matter as much as we think it
does about optimizing tiny little things
about how people understand um
uncertainty or ranges or confidence
intervals for example
the key thing is that you focus on
getting across that core message and
getting it across
excessively and finally just
we should all um be aware that we have
this incredibly powerful tool in
animation
and there are plenty of charts where we
would unthinkingly just produce a static
chart
but an animation can have that much more
i would say in fact orders of magnitude
more impact
and i'm going to end with a call to
action in terms of things that i would
like us as the date of his community to
do
differently or do more or even do for
the first time
as we as we go away from this which is
that first of all
as i mentioned at the very start there's
a huge amount of um huge amount of
resources out there on
how to achieve particular technical or
visual effects in a chart but there's
not very much
on the general way of framing your work
and the language you use around it in
order to achieve the clearest possible
communication of a message so what i'd
love to see and what i hope to
participate in myself
is putting out more resources that can
help people
think of and refine this idea of data
business communication
more than database just as a technical
exercise of creating
the the most objectively good chart
possible
and secondly i'd like us to be more to
think about accessibility in the
broadest of senses when we make our
charts
because we love making charts and
because we know other people
most people on this call i'm sure on
this uh on this session
um love looking at charts it can be very
easy to get into the trap of
thinking oh what's the what's the
coolest thing i can do here that other
chart people will love
how can i push the envelope how can i
make this this chart
um you know especially exciting and
impressive to people
who like charts but that is the
tiniest tip of the iceberg and the rest
of this enormous
thing beneath the surface of the sea is
non-chart people it's people who last
looked at charts when they were age 16
17 18 and then got the hell away from
them
probably people who tried to even avoid
spreadsheets but that is an enormous
enormous audience of people who could
love charts if they just had charts that
spoke to them
and charts that didn't try to be too
smart
charts that didn't condescend to them so
the other thing i'd love us all to do is
think more about making charts
not that are graphics for graphics
editors as uh
someone once said to me but charts that
are for your mum your dad
and you know everyone else out there in
the world
so thank you very much for bearing with
me through all of this and
please do find me all your questions and
i'd also encourage you in the spirit of
what i've been saying here
do you send me a tweet or an email or
anything like that with other questions
you have if we don't get time for them
just now because i'd love to hear your
thoughts
on all of this stuff
[Music]
you